Oh
Dating may seem impossible at times especially if you're not used to putting yourself out there
It's scary when you have to worry about putting your heart on the line
Not only that but it's a lot of hard work and time investment
You've discovered that even though you're actively dating you're still on the search for a meaningful connection with someone
Here are five ways to find true love if you're an introvert and hate dating
One go to events and places that reflect your favorite hobbies and interests
Forget hitting the bar or club to meet people if that's not where you feel like you can be your natural self
Meeting new people that you can potentially get to know over time requires a certain sense of self confidence
By going to events and places that Harbor your hobbies and interests
It'll be easier for you to strike up conversations based on similarities alleviating some of the stress introverts face when it comes to small talk
To be prepared to go through trial-and-error
Love is in a fairy tale and while you may hate the superficial
Aspects of dating you certainly can't go through it without getting your heart broken a few times or breaking someone else's
There's always a lesson to be learned in the world of dating for instance you might be used to
Internalizing your thoughts and feelings as an introvert
But while dating you'll learn to get better at communicating with your partner and even though that might be difficult at times it isn't impossible
3 have honest conversations
Don't be afraid to show who you are right from the beginning as
An introvert you value authenticity and depth anyway if you want to skip out on trying to impress others be honest
Have the difficult
Conversations ask them if they know where the both of you are headed see if the two of you actually have chemistry
but also
Communicate that you're willing to make things work
If you're serious about dating you shouldn't have to worry about waiting for a certain amount of time to pass before responding back to text
Messages or coming off as desperate or clingy to like someone is to still choose to be with them even on their worst days
Four: only make time for people you're really interested in don't date someone because they seem impressive on paper
Or if there's someone your parents and friends will approve of ask yourself what you really want in a partner
And only make time to meet up with people who you truly believe you are compatible with at the end of the day
You're the one dating that person not anyone else as an introvert
You most likely don't like creating conflict and rejecting those
You don't think you can have a relationship with it'll help you be one step closer to finding the right match
Additionally don't settle just because you're afraid to be alone
Five keep an open mind
This includes dating extroverts who operate in a different way who's to say dating someone who's your opposite
Can't work out? the key word is compromise as long as you and your partner respect each other's boundaries
There's no real reason as to why things can't work out even if misunderstandings may arise from time to time that's normal in any relationship
Are you an introvert? What helps you in the realm of dating feel free to share in the comments below on a
Different note psyched ago is planning to make some cool merch for you guys, and we're taking suggestions
So let us know if you have any ideas in the comments below also
Be sure to check out our website and other social media as well as our new patreon account for more content and don't forget to
subscribe, thanks for watching